good horde tell you you gotta say with
me your heart not hole let's get the
rumble in your blood horde I'm already
to rumbling you're scared Admiral boy
dead you're dead you're dead horde all
right there
hi everybody we're playing good [ __ ]
this is manga minx say hi hi everyone hi
hi manga minx
I assume you're recording on your hands
oh hi everybody from megaminx to channel
2 I am indeed recording as well hi ok so
let's go into good org it's ready up
where I intentionally tried to find a
bad game with co-op so that I could play
with megamix and we're gonna play good
horde and kill somebody that every time
I like the way you say you're like that
little sidekick that repeats all right
dead yard oh there's a story wait
there's actually a story to this day one
I haven't lady jack oh oh well I'll read
anyway a deadly military design virus
created to wipe out live another screw
this is stupid
dead horde continued with a dead card
okay
alright I'm red you're green or wait
maybe it's the other way around that she
on my screen okay oh god horn okay so we
got to go fight the Horde of dead
yeah I gotta figure I might be dead
hordes in this I don't know why I've got
idea then well be on the lookout we
don't on any dead hordes sneaking up on
us it seems to me to stink lack of
hordes of dead things at the moment they
yeah it's a good horde
the graphics of this game er intercept
in person oh my god there's a bear that
was already on you this game is for not
oh there's a flashlight did you know was
that one oh it's died okay I think he's
dead
give me one second yeah okay sorry I'm
gonna turn it right down now - let me I
got it I'm killing
look dead bored that's much better it
was actually just an innocent little
doggy who's trying to come up and say hi
and uh I kind of shot it in the face
oh no it's part of the dead horde okay
was a police dog and it was only one day
after retirement boy
that's always a story did you have you
played Saints Row 4 yet I have a knife
oh there's this one part in there where
are you killing guards and they're like
boom two weeks or German please a movie
quote ah and then you stab him in the
neck five times that's hilarious
who's hole oh that's it what's that
whoa I don't know I just rolled back I
just blew up as well for like no reason
was he your boomer how much can we gasp
at this horrifying game it's just so
scary have quite a game is scary before
in my life I know and we're poor like
professional horror players amnesia has
nothing on this stuff
Oh even machine for pigs can compare to
dead or yeah I'm something no excited
about machine pigs after playing this
I'm like wow this has got it just I'm
just somersaulting kit dude die I'm just
so scared I you the jet board I just
kept hope super holding on my screen
it's like you're like face clubs digna
crap okay so it said we owe one more of
the dead horde here shoot it thank you
okay you didn't shoot it you're just
standing there okay
area clear gates opening oh wow it's
like a wave combat thing alright
ah no nothing those in the market I feel
yeah definitely not especially one this
well implemented and fine-tuned I mean
look at the variations hahahaha you have
a grenade you know I have a grenade oh
you threw a grenade that's why I blew
dumb hand wait are we tonight is it just
me are they not dying okay there they go
coordinated fire on the dead horde is
very very good good good dead horse
oh this game with you right here ten out
of ten the easy easy easy my favorite I
love this you're like popping in and out
a like twelve frames a second that's
awesome so well optimized beat it comes
to thirty at the moment which concerns
me
the only recording it what huh 30 what
30 frames per second alright what you
say what huh
what's it weapons wait I don't know
somehow we were collecting gold from the
dead or and we can go get some weapons
now I'm not really sure what I'm doing
here I that's monster st ah what does
this mean what is a revived kit why
would you know I'm gonna get the shotgun
okay and then what I'm doing um I'm
gonna get it right I can't get a revive
kit cuz it's really expensive yeah you
need to kill more dead and get that
newbie bird meat okay ready
uh yeah I'm just buying that I bought
the assault rifle thing whatever that is
I'm gonna wait I bought the shotgun were
how do i I threw a grenade where died
how do I shoot wait i right clicked and
it happened and I can't get my shotgun
where's my shotgun I just want it fine
ah
I think he's a businessman oh yeah our
judge all right fine whatever I just
wasted some money on that okay back to
fighting the dead horde you didn't
follow its pace today that whoa whoa oh
yeah I didn't tell you about that oh now
we could do some squeeze Valerie oh god
it's okay it's fine it's only a dead
hole doctor I mean dead heart yes
you must say dead horde in your
respective manners or else no no no no
will like this video that we're making
it's total crap isn't it this game it
sucks bad we could like a place for days
Alice weeks Yeah Yeah right right right
definitely it's definitely not extremely
boring nothing's happening and totally
unintuitive definitely not sweet rave
party yeah some results I see the best
part games and is it like a melee that I
can I can't move I can't mow
okay I'm looking occult dislikes is
there can you throw away we have no
grenades doing this would be a perfect
time for a grenade ow ow ow my face
looking tag I'm diving out here yeah
have fun Magnum eggs
come on I'll write him today oh there's
an invisible wall
there was an invisible there okay wait
night
Oh fine I'll start it I can't get it
there's kind of a dead horde in the
middle of there all right that was worth
it now was it oh no mark McDo no okay
all right that's enough okay okay he's
gonna die now this is this is my normal
difficulty by the way this isn't even
close to the hardest you know the other
game we played that you played primal
face exactly like this I know except I
think prowl fierce was a little better
but it was lower reviewed on the actual
scheme website okay just somersault away
they can't possibly keep up with us in
here away from the dead horde they go
there
oh we're gonna separated uh just get up
here
I need your well I don't need your help
cuz all the zombies are around you I'm
doing fine
oh hello okay oh no that's all right bad
strategy proceed enter a vehicle oh yeah
wait what do we do with it
come on understand I'm inside do you
have a gun hey my gate oh we have a
ready okay whoo wow this is amazing this
is so uh whoops sorry all right hang on
wait no huh Oh dr. Jackie we're dark
okay we're good we're good we're good
okay all right hang on damn it that's a
ball okay just keep shooting and we're
doing fun like like better than Resident
Evil 5 I think I never played Resident
Evil 5 so I have no idea okay nevermind
oh okay jeez I thought you're giving
some honest honest praise for this
game's amazing gameplay it's pretty
amazing actually
it is it was pretty nice it might be
with that okay so now what Buffy and we
had to go back and kill those ones that
we miss cuz the gate won't open in this
we day well don't get out of the car
then we got a wait we can take this we
can take this all the way over there
let's try and get it up I like how
there's two guns on the side but you're
shooting from some imaginary thing
the top yeah that's totally realistic
allow a man excuse me
Jeep you're in my way [ __ ] yeah who's me
so steadily come on Stan almost said
yeah it's good all right I think we get
Jeff good enough nice parking by the way
thank you
there's no zombies over here we gotta
find the ones that we get ha ha ha ha I
think we might break the gate
uh well you don't know that maybe there
was one over here hang on actually we're
gonna we're gonna take this all right
hey see if there's any better shoot that
gun
sent me this better yeah that's the
stuff ah realism right there beautiful
okay it's um zom zoms we're looking for
zom zoms sounds answer zombies when you
say it's a fatal design floor if you
could have skipped by a zombie Zoe Ron
and you need it press cuz I would say
probably it is like aha
zom zoms they're coming out of the walls
this one's stuck on the wall next it was
like my [ __ ] i oh hang on I'm trying to
crush him but I can't move so just bear
with me for a second jig there with me
good bear with me all right one I see
one last one over there there are two
last ones and gays omen yeah we're gonna
make it into the next area oh my god
there's a dead body here quick use your
detector aha
Oh gate closed okay yeah I snuck
something you got I don't have it it
didn't give me it
I don't know what happened I really
don't can I Drive I can do it hard
dead Ord okay I blame them oh you play
everyone blames the dead horde but it's
not you know sometimes we have to
understand what we cause problems
ourselves there's an explosive barrel
over here I'm gonna leap into okay where
that this one this one right here how do
you know it's a positive ID I don't you
know I exploded myself to death I could
handle the stress of the dead horde was
pretty intense wasn't it
yeah pretty nice way to go I think she
might actually be permanently I might be
too I don't see any way for me to
respond cuz you didn't we didn't ever
bought one of those respawn kits is that
just my dead body kind of kneeling in
the dirt there am i standing straight up
I'm not sure it could be that I think it
is yeah ha ha yay okay don't don't
desecrate my body don't do weird things
after I'm dead just move on for me move
on without me she look like you might
come back as one of the Dead Boys
oh no I've become a part of the dead
horn okay all right carry on I I know
okay wait there's if you if you lunge
over the thing to the left to the left
to the left that's to the right to the
left to the left
up up up up up up up up in there way
back there nope that was a fence never
mind I'm stupid oh I want to be back so
I can kill myself
brutally oh hang on hang on oh look at
that
cool I could have driven that forklift I
was gonna but I didn't and you just lift
this thing here by the list of things
maybe you'll respond I'm 30 maybe can
you pick up my dead body and then place
me somewhere nice okay I want to try but
you I see now spazzing out on my screen
like spinning I'm still just kneeling on
mine so it's totally okay man
totally okay sorry my rock-hard abs are
preventing you from picking me up it's
okay just try to get through the gate
then carry on without remember what the
controls said it has a little thing up
but I've forgotten already
we'll get out and get back in maybe it
will tell you again hmm press up or down
Wow
is it this isn't like you need to go
down first that's not correct that is
not correct
okay down and now up
ah you're like The Incredible Hulk now
get out I think you need to get out of
it and then you can go under it yeah I'm
alive awesome
I'm alive Oh dad I don't say it I feel
perfectly normal megamix yeah I think I
could see a piece of your brain hang out
back your skull no no that's just a new
hairdo is perfectly fine ignore it
ignore the dead horde can you get me a
one second again no carry on without you
what's wrong where's our that
hard-packed by the dead [ __ ] word
megohm exit numbers poor eating it
nibbling on you okay there we go don't
shoot that arrow and I'm being nibbled
on these things don't die ah why you
killed us both why we was a worthy
sacrifice yes I know to the dead horde
my true masters what did you say
another nothing I did look you looked
wonderful in a look really tasty don't
you oh my god so many can't run away
from her then slowing me down I can't
get away throw grenade you don't have a
grenade that has made another shot gap
in the middle of nowhere so I think
selling useless shotguns that don't go
into my inventory I'm using my epic
dodge moves to get away it's um super oh
for these guys can I just point out
logon janessa probably the worst guns
like every ya know these shoot you know
these don't shoot regular bullet so you
shoot cotton balls that kind of just
pepper them and then they fall down
because they can't move anymore okay
yeah
I'm going to die like that cotton ball
out my bellybutton then they collapse
yep exactly then their arm falls off and
then everything just goes to [ __ ] Jana
uh ha ha see my sweet moves I don't want
to like criticize the game over say but
we do seem to be doing the same thing
quite a lot of the moment what you'd
seen it's repetitive and boring how dare
you
that's awful ok this game isn't
meticulous and overused that's
ridiculous
how dare you I'm really sorry I won't
ever say that again
how dare you if that's doing something
but I'm not reachable okay guys leave it
grin cuz it's green on my screen right
now so yeah three green sounds good sad
news magic color everyone loves okay
okay thank you thank you for being
concerned about my health we got to be
careful when it comes to the dead horde
that's gonna nibble on your brains your
delicious brains you know you died too
aren't you convert of the Dead hood
oh you probably could have used that
well I still need that okay more than I
did okay good thank you
Tara nope how about over here nope I
didn't decide to meet Franks
yeah well probably nothing probably
tasty delicious Marines is mine I'm
Gareth too bad sorry did you need
uh it's like we can't even do a headshot
in this thing it's just kind of shoot
until they drop
oh well game of the year I guess game of
the year
I call my for the game meteor addition
to come out actually with all the DLCs
oh man I bought in every DLC so far I
mean it went dead horde island edition
dead horde pets dead horde university it
was all amazing a lot yeah that was a
pretty good my everyone was dead horde
dead boy yeah how did I forget that one
that was 180 students that classic
wasn't it
okay I think we're lost pretty sure were
lost no way to go there's no worries
everybody
he said that button was supposed to do
something yeah yeah excuse me while I
somersault ahead I like how that energy
bar below our health isn't a sprint bar
it's a somersault bar is really
innovative I think is the word I'd use
to describe that yes innovative is that
how you English ladies pronounce it
innovative and is about sure to add
number Erika consisting of four letters
that rhymes with twit hahahaha
yo you mean yolo swagg
four letter words I know were you
talking about
okay anyway so how do we uh Oh over here
whoa
well I look at all this space wow this
path and this rain hail I you know what
dad horn probably in the would any other
look haven't seen these models before I
think we call them every time we say
dead hoard or sorry good Ord monsters
seem to come out of the walls
yeah like in that film where they say
that pain it's like Voldemort is that
what you mean dead hordes wall bunch of
dead Voldemort's come out of the walls
and then try to eat our brains a bunch
of dead well Dumont's come out the walls
and try and eat our brains okay alright
best not Michael everywhere it's
ridiculous it's like a horde
I did award gosh-dang
bets I thought I so did an enemy dad but
I didn't know like oh I love the
different variety of types you got your
runners
you got your joggers you got your quick
walking people
you got your shirtless guys the not
quite wearing shirt guys the guys with
pants and no shirts this is all great
love it love it so much
I can tell that the creators of the
models really took that time with this
guy and you know didn't rush it out or
anything that's phenomenal I mean really
I mean you can definitely tell how our
character models are differentiated by
green red yeah the green in red it's
such a little bit but beautiful gun good
house yes what a talent where does his
elves come from I guess the zombies have
it like stored are you gonna yell
something just like all the gold that
shoots out of their ass once they fall
over and then we pick up and readily
stuff into our pockets uh can't ever
have enough Oscar okay it's my favorite
Viper Gold
that's how you get gold out of
leprechauns you pick him up and you
squeeze him real hard ain't gold shoots
out of their ass well I I did a
somersault and then I saw like just
lagged into them often but there's a
helps over here I'm gonna steal it from
you no no no no help
get away get away get away get away get
away why are there keep invisible walls
whenever we try to summer tall I don't
know I planned the invisible rolls
myself yeah I blame reward glad we're on
the same page in that one yeah
definitely the same page not like we
discussed it beforehand no no no no we
just started automatically saying dead
horde Cos Cob
Whistler witty loved the game so much
I'm sure no one watching it is tarah
tired of us saying gut horde over and
over night
hey horde of dead okay here's another
there's another button here I can't
reach it
yeah we'd probably like wiped out Hoth
population of the country launching
nukes by pressing these pallets hmm I
don't think they would put nuke controls
on the outside of doors
oh there's a dead heart No
it's not really a hoard it's more of a
dead hmm look okay all right you take
care of hike hey this actually works out
pretty nicely do you see me I see this
you soon he's I found my shotgun I only
have six bullets
bullseye said I had full ammo before
that was a worthwhile investment oh that
sucks
well I'm glad I have infinite rifle ammo
I guess I pulled that out of my ass and
then when you turn into a zombie
it turns into gold oh I get it the goal
you fire gold bullets and then you pull
them out of the zombies when you're done
genius drives me Game of the Year cuz
everyone knows the only thing that kills
a zombie it was a golden bullet that's
the well-known piece of real life backs
about real-life zombies sorry I'm like a
PDS that must be Trey yes exactly Mary
oh my god edit Wikipedia okay this thing
turned green gate open Daenerys party
yeah yeah get to you in a second oh that
was a dog he okay we're done yeah hey I
think I'm gonna we did it oh I did it I
did it without you I didn't need you
doing everything without me everything
will I killed a hundred ninety-nine why
did it seem like we killed a thousand
maybe cuz they took over seven million
bullets to kill oh my god well I'm tired
of this
good luck haha hey hey they mean it was
the most gripping exciting game you've
ever played yeah you excited yeah when I
say then I'm done with this I meant like
I can't handle this much excitement in
my chest I mean I have to say that this
pain in my arm must be all the wondrous
excitement that I'm feeling for this
game either there is an oncoming heart
attack and the excitement no could be
either one who knows I might be dead and
join the dead horde pretty sad right so
anyway I guess this is goodbye
we hope you enjoyed this game as much as
we did it was a fantastic roller coaster
ride of an adventure through the annals
of time so many emotions so little time
glad to have shared
journey this is better than journey like
always been a story better graphics
everything mm-hmm just the emotions of
the dead horde kill them description
okay so thanks again everybody for
watching thank you manga mix for joining
me in having me it was a fun wiping it
today away right now I'm shedding them
openly haha bye everybody bye
I've played the cabbage
oh okay
presentation that's like yeah
there's some guy carrying
I would be dying anytime soon why not
his only Kerrigan appoint her in the
boss fights like yes